black holes have a region around them
called the photon sphere and this is a
region where light can wrap around many
times around the black hole coming
pretty close to its original position
before either spiraling out very far
away from the black hole or falling into
the black hole so if you want to see the
back of your head go near a black so the
light is basically in orbit around the
black hole that's right
yeah so you look straight ahead
and you will see light that headed
backwards and came around to the front
of your face and that would be your your
nap the nappy back your head that's
right that's what we're talking about
right right wow that is so cool that
would make for a weird picnic you know
do you know who you're looking at right
the front and the back of them at the
same time and then you walk towards them
but you don't know which one you look I
mean yeah that would that's it that's
that's something somebody needs to do in
a movie yeah oh absolutely imagine it'd
be very disorienting